So let's talk about, how to enable a mobile
applications, to access the end point functions that you've defined,
in your Conference Central application. So, here's the Android
app that we have, that will access the Conference Central
app, running on Udacity. So you've already learned about
setting the client Ids, to specify the clients that are
allowed to access your backend API. Well, to allow
a mobile application to access the backend API. You have
to add the client ID for your mobile app as well. So here we're looking at the
@api definition at api definition in the conference
api class. And here we've specified the clientIDs. We've
got the web client ID. And here you
see we've specified the Android client ID. And if
we had an iOS ID, we would specify that here as well. We have the API explorer
client ID. And we've been using the Constants.Java
class to hold our client IDs, as well as
other constants. So this is my client ID, my
web client ID. And then here is where I
would put the Android client ID when I have it. So one other thing that you need
to set for Android apps, is you need to
specify the Android audience. So the client IDs list
protects the backend API list from unauthorized clients.
But further protection is needed to protect the client,
so that their [INAUDIBLE] can work only for
the intended backend API. And for Android clients we
use the audiences attribute to specify which backend
API's they can connect to. So the value of
the audience's attribute needs to be, the web client
ID of the apps that the Android app will
connect to. So, looking again at constance.java, in this case
we set the android audience to be the Web Client
ID of this conference central application. So, when you create
your Android Client ID, you're going to need to know
a couple of things. You got to need to know
the package name of the classes in your Android application
and you're also going to need to have to show
one fingerprint of your application. When you build your Android
app in debug mode, the STK automatically creates the
debug key inside the application with it. You can also
generate a new key. To do this, you'll need
to specify the key's full name and the key store
alias. So I'm going to go ahead and generate
a new key. So I call the keytool passings dash
genkey and then I specify the keystore name, which
I've very kindly called keystore dash name.keystore. Need to specify
an alias for the keystore, which I've cunningly named keystore dash
alias. Then I'm going to need to enter a password. And you
can pick whatever password you want, just remember it. Then it's
going to ask some questions. Go ahead and answer the questions. Then
at the end, make sure you say yes to actually go
ahead and do it. And then it's going to ask you to
enter the password for the keystore alias. And if you want
to use the same password as you just entered before, then just
press Return. Now I've created my new key. To
create the Android client ID, I'm actually going to need
the SHA1 fingerprint of the new key. And to
get that, I'm going to call keytool, and you specify
the ex, -exportcert. You need to provide the alias.
My case it was just keystore-alias. And the keystore name
under my case it was just keystore-name.keystore. So now
I need to enter the password. And you see here
it gives us the certificate fingerprint. And here is is
actually the SHA1 value. So I'm going to need to copy
this whole thing here. You don't include the SHA1 colon,
but you include all the value of the SHA1. You're
going to need to copy that. You'll need that when you
create your Android client id. Okay, so now I'm going to
create my Android client id. And just as you did
with your client id for web application, you create your
Android client id in the developer's console over at
console.developers.google.com. So to do that, you choose the Credentials
screen and the app is in auth. Choose create
new client ID. And then this time, make sure
you choose install application. Select Android. Then you're going to
need to provide the package name, and this is
the package name of the classes in your android
app. And in our
case the package is com.google.devrel.training.conference.android.
going to need to copy over the shell one finger print.
Hope I got that right, you can leave deep linking disabled
and you create your client ID. Okay now you say,
I have the client ID for web application and the client
ID for android application and I am going to need to
take this client ID here and copy it. And over here,
in my source code, I need to enter the android client
ID. So one more thing you're going to need to do
is to generate the client library containing your endpoints
API. Once you've got the client library, your mobile app
will be able to include it so that it
can make calls to the endpoints API. For Android apps
generating the client library is very straight forward. In
the terminal window go to the directory containing your projects
pom.xml file. Here's my pom.xml. Then you need to run the command to get the
client live. MVN appgengine:endpoints_get_client_lib.
Now the process runs. ‘Kay. Build success. I
always like the sound of that. Now whenever
you do a build the results go into
a target directory. So here’s our target directory.
Let’s go into it. And here you see the endpoints dash client dash libs. So go
into endpoints dash client dash libs and you’ll
see a folder with the name of your project.
Go into that folder. Now go ahead and
invoke maven to build the client library. This is
very simple. You just do MVN. Install. Now it's
building. Now it's done. This builds the required class
files and it creates the jar files that you're
going to need to add your client project. So now
we're done and we've got the target folder. And
you see, in the target folder we have this
snapshot jar. So this is the name of the
project. This is the version. Snapshot.jar. This is the
client library jar. You'll need to add this client
library jar to your Android app. The process of adding
the client library jar to your Android app and
also how to call the endpoints API inside your
Android client. It's very documented in the developer docs.
So we have, it explains how to generate the client
library, actually we already did that. So the docs explain how
to add the client library to the project. There's a couple
other things you need to do, you need to create a
service object and then there's a discussion of how to call
the backend API. And as well as the information in the
developer docs, so we've written a document that takes you through
the steps that you're going to need to do to get
an Android application to use the conference central end points API.
You'll also need to remember that if you do
change your backend API, you're going to regenerate your client
libraries and readd them to your clients. You can also
access your backend API from IOS apps. But since these
don't use Java, the process to generate the client
library is slightly different, and it's well documented in the
developer docs as well. So, you can read about it
in the developer documentation. Now that you've got the client
library for your mobile device, it's up to you how
to use the conference API in your mobile app. So the
Android app that comes with this course, the conf, the Udacity
Conference Central app, you can get it from Play store, is
very simple. And it's really only meant to be a
demo, so it's not fully functional. Basically, all it will do,
if it will query for the conferences, it will let you
register, and it'll let you unregister. But it doesn't do very
much else. Feel free to get the source code for the
Android app and to hook it up to work with your own
conference central application. You may need to make some small changes
to your backend API code, so be sure to check the instruction
notes for this video. These changes will make your backend API
code more [UNKNOWN] for all client apps. So we'll continue to work
with your WebUI clients as well as with Android apps. So also
feel free to extend the source code from the Android app to
call more of the back end API, as you like.